hallo mein Name ist Luca und ich bin
schwerhörig bin ich eigentlich nicht
aber wir tun heute mal so weil sonst
wird das Video keinen Sinn ergeben da
ich schwerhörig bin habe ich mir gedacht
ich lade mir noch mal den TCH Spot Sound
Booster runter mit dem man die
Möglichkeit hat seinen PC von einer
maximalen Lautstärke von
100% die wir hier gerade haben
hochzuschrauben auf insgesamt
500% und das machen wir heute ich habe
Angst
oh mein Gott oh mein
Gott was geht hier ab irgendwas passiert
hier oh mein
Gott
diger was waren das für Wassergeräusche
da war nicht mal Wasser
okay ich glaube wir müssen
einfach ach ich ist auch
scheißegal voll Idiot nirgendswo hier
ist Wasser wo höre ich Wasser
oh okay oh mein Gott ist das laut
diger das geht nicht ich habe eine Biene
meinem rech es geht nicht ich wünschte
ihr hättet zu Hause diese Kopfhörer auf
das ist das schlimmste was ich je
gemacht
habe oh mein
Gott
Alter ist das alles laut was passiert
wenn ich das Ding ich will das Ding
nicht mal schlagen ich will einfach oh
was war das denn und wo kommt das Wasser
her das ist so schrecklich gerade okay
wir brauchen zwei Holz oh mein Gott ich
sterbe wir machen uns die Eichenstämme
machen uns daraus eine Werkbank aus den
hier machen wir uns
Stücker
bitte dieses
dreckspferd wow Alter ich kotze mein
Arsch ne diger geht das
laut
dugeburt meine Fresse oh ich muss ganz
schnell weg okay wir
bra alter Schwede meine Nachbar wer mich
hassen weil ich das Gefühl weil so
laut weil so laut ist mein oh dass ich
auch so laut reden muss ich das Ding das
SE viel zu laut dieses laufen aber es
geht halt nicht anders ich glaube ich
muss einfach unter Wasser ich muss
einfach unter Wasser irgendwo hin
au Bruder hat das jemals schon mal
irgendwer
gemacht Bo ist schrecklich
ha ich will weg von allem was hier ist
oh mein Gott es ist laut oh mein Gott es
ist laut ich will weg von allen Tieren
ich Stapp mir den Baum hier vorne hol
mir ein bisschen Holz dann holen wir uns
Steine an dieses laufen habe ich mich
mittlerweile schon ein bisschen
gewöhnt es tut so weh
[Musik]
euch an alle die sagen dass ist gespielt
das tut so weh ich sehe schon wieder die
Kommentare es tut so weh in den Ohren
ladet euch dieses drecksprogramm selbst
runter warte das heißt das ist von
texbot aber das Ding heißt
lasoft.com ich ich Blend euch hier
ein vielleicht müssen wir bei dem ganzen
kr aber auch gegensätzlich vorgehen dass
ich gar nicht laut reden
muss ich wusste nie dass diese
Lautstärke dass diese Dinger die da
rechts reinfen dass die so laut sein
können ich wollte sagen vielleicht
müssen wir gegensätzlich vorgehen und
einfach Bo ist es la oh mein Gott ist es
laut das kannst du dir nicht
ausdenken das ist das schlimmste
was ich hier gemacht
habe also for real Kohle geil e das
ist das hört sich immer an wie ein Pferd
guck mal jetzt oben rechts wenn das
jetzt wieder
weggeht das sind schon schöne Sounds die
hatte man nie auf dem Schirm ich wollte
aber sagen oh dass wir vielleicht
gegensätzlich vorgehen müssen das heißt
dass ich einfach so ein bisschen leiser
reden
muss soass wir einfach alles das was
okay ich glaub es bringt gar
NS es tut so weh in den Ohren es tut so
weh in den Ohren
ah das ist einfach wie so ein
so wie so ein Laserstrahl man die ganze
laserl
instagram.com/er das heutige Video ist
wirklich einfach nur purer
Schmerz
Unterwasser ist auch ganz interessant
ne das hör sich an als wä ich in
irgendeiner Rakete oder
so
Höhle ichri Nackenschmerzen davon was
für Nackenschmerzen Schmerz mein ganzen
Körper
ich
perfek eine
notaufnahmeer Wasser und der über Gras
läuft ist das schlimmste was ich hier
erlebt habe ach so und an alle unter
euch zur Info ich habe quasi dreimal das
lauteste was geht viermal ich habe
minecraft auf 100% weiß nicht ob ich
euch das schon gezeigt habe minecraft
auf 100% dann wenn ich einmal kurz
umstelle auf Vollbild ich habe auch mein
PC auf 100% ich habe dies Sound Dings
auf 500% und mein Audio Interface kann
ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen habe ich
auch auf voller Lautstärke und sogar
Kopfhörer auf also wenn sich einer heute
so richtig dann ich mich selbst ich GLB
meine hab bisschen gewöhnt das ist so
wie wenn man im Club ist
undch
nicht ich will wieder Wasser l mich
Rakete
se das ich interstell wenn man hier
unter Wasser ist das ist entspannt das
nicht entspannt ist das
jetzt okay die Sonne geht schon wieder
unter das heißt wir brauchen auf jeden
Fall ein Bett
erstal ich B nicht wieder raus
raus was kommt schon wieder an irgendwas
läuft doch schon wieder
diger es tut so weh komm ich will
wenigstens eine Nacht geschlafen dann
ist zumindest so ein kleiner
Erfolg ich will kein Tier
töten ich töte ich will einfach ich ma
mir
[Musik]
Brunnen das ist nicht normal kurz noch
Maler crafting Bench dann den craften
zack Ofen hier rein Eisen verbren so das
für
uns
ist das Ding einfach so gestorben ach Mo
Meister wo sind denn jetzt die anderen
scha Alter hier war noch vor drei
Schafe wo sind jetzt hin oh mein gott
hat der Wolf alle getötet da müss
irgendw noch mehr au noch mehr Wolle
liegen hier ist
nichts und ist
nichtsung ist auch nichts hier oh hier
oh und hier auch oh guck mal perfekt
wolle nach oben eichenholzbretter nach
unten wir haben Bett und gehen
schlafen dier dieser Ofen das kann mir
doch keiner sagen dass er schon immer so
laut war aber gut wir haben einen
kompletten Tag in Minecraft auf
500przentiger Lautstärke geschafft meine
lieben Freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
ich glaube nicht